what is happening there citizens of the reject
Nation we are here to watch the Wednesday
finale what a journey it's been John how are
you I am very excited and I'm also not ready
to let go I am filled with woe to do so how
are you good don't worry we'll milk it yeah
so much Wednesday today they should season
two predictions everything ladies and gentlemen
first off I want to thank you all who have
been on this journey with us it has been a
really fun ride I know we relate to it unfortunately
didn't get a single thing spoiled so thank
you guys for being awesome leave a like we
ask that kindly helps out the video please
go ahead and leave a like if you're excited
for season two and I know you are also subscribe
and click that notification Bell because I'm
sure there's something I'll pop up on this
channel that you're gonna be like yeah I like
that and uh full-length retro watch alongs
where you sync up with your own copy of Wednesday
available for our super sexy rejects over
there we cover exclusively several shows of
reaction highlights and watch alongs included
I want to thank everyone who has shown their
support by joining our patreon page thus far
all right John you ready to begin this journey
let's do it I'm ready as it'll ever be let's
go
[Music] you who's your master I was surprised
you wanted to see me again after you ran out
the other night is this a date no you try
to capture him what's going on so if you're
warned me about you but I didn't listen ironic
now huh ironic would have been framing Xavier
for murder while the real hide helped me put
him away I'm not a monster and if you really
thought that I was why would you risk bringing
me out to the woods to confront me alone you
said I was alone oh she's got her friends
and a big net oh Xavier wasn't invited because
he's in jail he's there in spirit and I'm
out of here actually
you're coming with us ah no pendants oh siren
perhaps if I hadn't been so distracted by
my own mother hogging this photo I would have
noticed yours sooner whoa your father fell
in love and married an outcast oh cool she
was a hide and your father has been living
his life in dread never really quite sure
whether or not she had passed her condition
on to you you're basing all this awesome Vision
you had after we kissed I mean is that something
you could trust oh yeah just some light torture
cut his head off
you mean serious there's only one thing that
a Hyde understands pain oh yeah that's it
I'm out
dude guys I didn't sign up for this let's
go to Weems explain everything Weems won't
help and Tyler here is always one step ahead
of his father you need at least one witness
Bianca stay dude hostile four is cool whatever
impress him on his mother or any sensitive
issue he's becoming cold and detached it's
like I'm talking to a different person I believe
the trauma of losing his mother may have left
Tyler with deeper psychological scars than
I suspected oh he is like a real Jekyll and
Hyde situation huh yeah but who's the master
Sheriff Galvin we have a problem [Music] 10
names Wednesday atoms Let's test your reflexes
[Music] yeah gotta torture faster
hey Wednesday if you still want to go on a
date you know just let me know I go to your
quad when I gave you that call from the cave
did you already know the truth Wednesday that's
enough Xavier Thorpe is our height we've got
evidence thanks to you and that's why I'm
giving you one last pass Tyler is going to
turn on you too oh is that your plan
ask a question what does it feel like what
does what feel like to lose what
I like it covered in blood no idea what happened
but over time started to remember everything
no oh no dude panic in her eyes fear is so
Primal I could taste it and it was delicious
oh man [Music] you have no idea the
storm is coming Miss Adams [Music] creep sociopath
it's not a Jekyll and Hyde it's all hide perhaps
if you'd come to me with your suspicions rather
than taking matters into your own hands we
could have worked together oh yes because
trust and cooperation I've always been the
Hallmarks of our relationship
pack your steamer trunks we will have them
shipped and say your goodbyes son of a [__]
Tyler used me to frame you he is the actual-eyed
there's some revenge for back in the day I
should have believed you but since you seem
to have some sort of psychic connection to
the hide I was curious to know if you've drawn
anything recently that might shed some light
on this side yeah so I'll get you out of here
yeah I mean Enemy of My Enemy I tried being
your friend look where that got me this isn't
about a savior no it's about you every time
you get people get hurt you're toxic slip
it under all you ever do is make things worse
foreign
go far away and never come back and never
return
I hope his thought process is immediately
followed by that was my one chance damn it
do I get another phone call she doesn't have
a phone she's the only one who knows the truth
will you forget about me the mark you have
left on me is indelible anytime I grow nauseous
at the side of a rainbow I hear a pop song
that makes my ears bleed I'll think of you
I always believe relying on other people to
be a sign of weakness that inevitably they
would lead me to disappointment facts ended
up in the disappointment wow this prophecy
cannot come true if I'm not here but it kills
me to leave when Tyler is still walking around
free if he tries anything we have a school
full of Gorgons vampires and werewolves ready
and waiting we've got this Wednesday I promise
we'll take down Lord Voldemort I got a text
from Eugene's moms he woke up last night maybe
we need to let you drop by on your way to
the station Eugene's got the answers so we're
gonna
not hugging is kind of our thing by the end
of the episode glad to see you're finally
awake I heard you visited me all the time
don't ever mention it again someone set fire
to that cave just for a moment thought that
they weren't black they were red
it is all right okay yeah that's right damn
it damn talked about it in the review of last
episode that might be her I should have known
it was you faking your death securing a job
and Nevermore unlocking a hide typically I
have great admiration for well-executed Revenge
plots but yours was a bit extreme even for
my high standards she left the dance and went
to back to the dance I guess so yeah
and correctly accused kimbot of using hypnosis
to unlock him would you use a plant derived
chemical didn't you yeah of course you manipulated
him by showing him what his mother truly was
now what Tyler didn't realize is that the
truth wouldn't free him
interesting and that was scary at first I
used the cave and the shackles
ugh that's enough I showed you who you really
are and what they did to your mother I hope
Tyler confesses to someone else prior we were
never getting on that train I sent Tyler to
intercept you I never made it to the station
[Music] of course I was like why is he why
is he agreeing with her now please don't make
this more difficult than what already is Marilyn
[Music] I feel like we should have prepared
for that oh come on
oh you gotta be kidding me the mouth foam
the past repeats no nitrate poisoning A fitting
end don't you think oh [__] who the hell
damn it
thing damn I'm bummed principal Williams and
her went in front of Miss Thornhill but I
haven't heard a Pete from either of them why
would they confront the Stoneham because she's
behind and it's happened she's the bad guy
bad woman she's a really bad person
slow down what happened [Music] huh what the
hell is going on what about Wednesday Tyler
and Thornhill took her down to the Old Mill
you need to call the sheriff mom I've got
to go Wednesday's my only friend and if she's
in trouble I've gotta help her type code I've
code go Rogue Eugene you know we have roots
that go all the way back to just crack snow
so you come from a line of psychotic Killers
too yep my family has remained committed to
crack Stone's Mission I decided to take a
different approach the supernatural Tyler's
been collecting all of these body parts to
resurrect crack Stone oh damn a Frankenstein's
monster he's gonna be an outcast by Design
you are the key goody sealed crack Stone in
his sarcophagus with a blood lock only one
of her direct descendants can open it perfect
that's her that's her something's going on
at Livermore okay get a couple cars over there
ASAP the tires of all the squad cars have
been slashed [__] sure yeah I've been
waiting to do that spin you better be ready
to kill your own son I'd be ready I'd be prepping
all my life [Music] it's always the palm thank
you
what's cracks don't gonna come out as a totally
normal guy until the cracks though
can you hand me my arm please [Music]
it's like the mummy
[Music]
ah yes foreign
God I love this what a fun spooky episode
yes
oh it looks fairly normal my Vengeance will
be Swift and true [Music] as will mine yeah
let's do this
oh what the [__] [Music]
we're ouch how could she survive that she
murdered Weems and then took Wednesday to
crack Stone's correct we have to get everyone
in the school to safety before it's too late
because this is what's coming so how do we
get everyone out we'll use our siren song
to convince him cool coerce everyone into
saving themselves what's going on Bianca's
mom's app season two bringing down a cult
crack storm must be stabbed through his black
heart it's the only way you will be vanquished
now and forever is your spectral vision impaired
I'm dying my mother told me it was for Conjuring
Visions it is also a conduit for contouring
spirits it will allow me to pass through you
and heal you just know once I do you will
never see me again one-time use [Music] yeah
really looks like I've been in the same shot
yeah [Music] [Applause] it's like a doctor
who energy transfer
what the hell is going on danger is on its
way no time
follow me I definitely remember that character
yep he was great I think during the Poke something
coaching somebody yes all right girl let's
do this
oh my God oh my God oh my God [Music]
[Applause] [Music] [Applause] [Music]
this will not end well for you
Daniel here we go
nice
so before he must have taken his clothes off
yes
eat it [Applause]
I can't tell you how I've long for this moment
what it means for my family
come by tongue from direction now wow some
things I guess your hero I like the makeup
on crack Stone I will expunge your Abominations
[Music]
oh damn [Music]
yes yes
it's a great reaction
it's time to talk about your mother Tyler
the sun is that really you
all right
damn this is crazy damn this is crazy eyes
slanky monster fight [Music]
now get her a towel everyone needs a modesty
towel
[Music] on Wednesday dude he got godric Gryffindor
Sword of the Sorting Hat how he howdy pilgrim
s Archer oh that was it's okay hold up magnum
Zoolander still cool
oh
selfless oh my God everybody go get them out
of here fly them out on your large Ravens
[Music] everything ow nice you just yanked
that out because damn it's probably ripped
a bigger hole in your shoulder
defense is coming back [Applause]
[Music] [Applause] oh no [Music]
is that a promise
Eugene please tell me it's Eugene
nice [Music]
finally damn wow
cool damn
oh merchandise
this [__] God damn it I might not get
to kill all the outcasts but at least I'll
get to kill you Wednesday nice Luger the bee
Eugene drowner and honey or something how
is he controlling Eugene controls the bees
he's a wicker man [Music] Candyman Eugene's
a candy man it's a species here that's what
you get for messing with Nevermore [__]
Hummers stick together yeah all of them and
what irony the plant lady gets taken down
by bees yeah yeah
ain't it
feels like an old school movie her mom is
going to be like you're such a disappointment
you couldn't even defeat the hide yes you're
not wolf enough where's Wednesday foreign
[Music]
[Music] [Laughter] [Music]
[Laughter] you too yeah bruh
lurch is she still going home it's a fake
out it's just for the winter break or something
school might be closed [Music]
question mark yeah
oh man they really killed her off I'm Legit
sad about that it's so fun to watch when I
was in the show I said a lot of things being
your friend should come with a warning label
but I don't know a lot of people who would
take an arrow for me so welcome to the 21st
century Adams nice buy her a phone
my number's in there already I hope you're
not expecting me to call you no never I'd
settle for a text though [Music] I don't know
what a text is right I wonder what a Wednesday
text reads like
[Music]
oh golly
oh [__] oh no maybe this forced vacation
will be more interesting than I imagined unlike
my novel not every thread has been tied up
nor every question answered secrets are still
lurking in the dark corners who's the stalker
is there a Tyler in there or Laurel Gates
and Tyler just pawned in a bigger game well
today's stalker become tomorrow's nemesis
[Music] what the hell guys I know the suspense
is killing you
it is give me more
I am it's good I mean there was something
after the credits I don't think Netflix would
be recommending Glass Onion that's true and
immediately skipping us ahead to the idea
that season two is coming yeah but I mean
we can uh wait I want a solid ass season finale
yeah man that was a really solid season finale
yeah it wrapped up everything very satisfying
very cathartic very fun all right let's go
over everything we got right yes
Tyler or Tyler that's about it Tyler and I
said oh wait no in in in in episode three
I said that uh oh my God forget his name right
now crack stone wood would come back and um
we didn't really commit to Christina Ritchie
no no after Ricky Lynn at home that's the
fun thing about this we can we can't Pat ourselves
on the back for that I was like oh okay we
can only Pat ourselves on the back for the
idea that I think we suspected something's
up with her but throughout we kept picking
up on the idea that that there's something
not being said about her and she is too they
both go out of their way to tell you tell
us that she's ignore me and she's just too
like good she's just like the one character
who's always good and not like too gray and
so yeah I said the episode with her parents
Enid that she a wolf out on episode eight
you did or was it was it her parents it was
some episode something about that about not
being able to Wolfhound I was like wait till
episode eight I know I work on all these edits
so I know yeah um yeah but um okay yeah that's
about it but we don't we can't give ourselves
Christina Ritchie see that's the fun thing
is there had multiple she wasn't bad uh Gwendolyn
Christie wasn't bad I thought I thought some
there's gonna be some other uh we couldn't
we couldn't pinpoint it we couldn't nail down
whether or not she was bad yeah up until the
very it wasn't until she revealed herself
like she's undercover I was like oh she's
good yeah she is good what do you know no
I thought they did really well they did really
well with especially that mislead and the
mislead of of uh Dr kenbot like yes I think
they did nicely to tear out Mysteries and
I almost wonder if the Tyler twist is sort
of intentionally the one you can most easily
guess uh because yeah you have that which
is the Bell we've been rigging this whole
time uh but then they have yeah these these
other mysteries on top as well as good red
herrings and I love that you get a dramatic
punch out of the idea that yeah Weems is willing
to bend the rules and do some deceptive things
for the greater good of the school but as
it turns out it really is it's for the greater
good of the school you know yeah yeah I mean
there's a lot there there's a couple things
that I craved a tad bit more out of I feel
like they keep giving the sheriff the sled
head when it comes to these emotional beats
because I wanted a better scene with him in
Gomez sure him and then him and Tyler don't
get that scene come on give us something about
him being like my son but you know I should
have been more involved emotionally with you
after we did talk about your mom I should
have learned my lesson yeah we should have
had we should have had because there was no
payoff to that after after everything would
you talk about ma um or wanted that I did
want that yeah and um I think the handle I
really loved a lot of the spookiness and it
was just a boisterous episode it was exciting
it felt like very Hollywood you know and I
really I love that touch I love that I love
that Flair it's like a it's not a Halloween
episode but it it sings of the Halloween spirit
sure you know like what with the seances and
the resurrection and these Frankenstein nods
and sure the makeup of them and then the werewolfing
out and the fight like I was so it was fun
and exciting and it was great it was a great
pulse about it throughout the whole episode
episode and Eugene having some ability to
control the Beast okay okay he's a Candyman
or a wicker man or some kind of zero is there
a term for that I don't I don't no no we're
looking it up because yeah do they explicitly
say what his uh what his ability or what his
you know category of uh otherness is ability
to control that's right he is at Nevermore
yeah yeah that's right for sure yeah we thought
he was just some guy at the at the B place
because I feel like they they go out of their
way to be like vampires werewolves Sirens
you know and then we got hides I guess uh
and the manipulation is
the ability
well as I recall it anyway that's kind of
all they give you is sort of like that's where
they meet and that's most of where you see
him and they're doing B stuff and and they
don't really get too personal about like why
are you at Nevermore what what kind of outcast
are you Eugene why don't you do an info dump
on you yeah like we learned more about who
Eugene is as a person in other ways but yeah
it is kind of funny to be like oh yeah what
is the what is the actual extent of your power
because of course you must have some kind
of power yeah or just disposite I guess Wednesday
is special she's got the Visions but even
before realizing that I guess she is there's
got to be a special auxiliary category for
people who are just a bit off and strange
and and outside of the you know accepted normal
the I like a lot of the emotional payoffs
like I really like the way the hug was done
with Enid and Wednesday yeah said she would
hug first episode said she would hug Pugsley
nah she did hugging you know Pugsley it's
a mystery episode of guessing you know come
on you like to figure out what you can get
right yeah yeah it's the whole fun of a show
like this across the board but uh you hugged
you know but the way that hug it was just
perfectly acted too yes like the way I love
the way they edited that with the slow motion
and then her pushing her away like you don't
realize until it goes behind yeah he did it
she's pushing her away it's so funny they've
played the fury yeah but the hug was like
such a tight one like the closed Fist and
everything it wasn't just some you know typical
embrace it was like a
she closes her eyes there at the end like
this hug will kind of continue like yeah it's
a really lovely moment the growth of having
friendships I think that was really strong
yeah I did really love the scene when Tyler
Reveals His True Colors I thought that was
excellently done where you're like oh holy
[__] he's just an [__] oh my God he's
been pretending this time he's aware of it
all oh my God well that's a that's a good
I think another great little it's like yeah
it's it's a sub mystery but it's like okay
so Tyler must be the monster but you almost
assume that he must just not know and then
having that layer is like oh no like it still
manages to have a reveal on top of the reveal
you were expecting which I think helps and
is nice is good however proceeding with Tyler
in the episode he did just become kind of
one now he just because yeah he just becomes
muscle Hench yeah yeah I know what and he
became a lot less interested and I was like
well as much as I love that scene and the
way that was done he is just relegated backwards
a little bit and he has one note so he's nowhere
near as interesting to watch where I'm like
but if they did the choice where he he was
like a real Jekyll and Hyde situation I thought
they were setting that up I don't know that
was the mislead was that they were setting
up that he is like a Jekyll and Hyde and that's
why the there's a turn at the at the at the
police station where he's like how does it
feel to lose like it's a great line reveal
yeah but if they committed to the Jekyll and
Hyde thing he might have remained a little
bit more interesting that's what I'm saying
is it because they'd bother to show that bit
where you're seeing some flashback of or he's
listening to the tapes the dad's listening
to the tapes of kinbot's sessions and her
being like whenever I bring up his mom he
changes and gets really cold and and it's
not like he's hulking out but it seems like
oh yeah there's a different personality in
there maybe he was at first and then Christina
Ricci uh maybe that's it yeah it's like maybe
when it's latent it just is your demeanor
but when it's really unlocked it's the full
spectrum or something yeah and I I thought
that was a really well done um I I think Christina
Ritchie had a ton of fun I think it was smart
it that is good casting because even the moments
early on like when it came to her first learning
about the secret society it was very obvious
the way Christina was she played it like oh
no I don't I don't know she obviously knew
about the Nightshade Society uh the way how
she would sometimes play off like she doesn't
know something but you're like she clearly
knows yeah um however but casting her works
on a great audience level because you're like
it's Wednesday I trust that's trust that's
great meta casting so you're not really going
to you know fully expect it yeah it said throws
you off till close to the end which I thought
was really well done like I fully believed
it was the therapist when they said it yeah
um yeah totally it wasn't until they got rid
of her was like oh my because it has to be
Christina Ritchie now yeah yeah yeah so uh
that the way that's that reveals done and
she does become you know the thing is so much
of it is saved by it's it's it it the way
it Embraces its camp and the way it Embraces
its heightened spirit and like yeah does she
become just I'm evil villain now like yeah
she does this correct Stone just become monster
back from the dead I don't care about anything
yeah yeah yeah like does it become that sure
but it's it has such a great fun tone and
the production with it to support that tone
so that's why I'm like sure could you do a
little bit more I absolutely you could and
and I'm not just giving it a pass because
of that it I feel like it's they did what
I get the impression they did what they wanted
to do you know and I like I really liked it
a lot what they decided to do and it did feel
ultimately fulfilling by the end well yeah
because it's not the most important thing
to do it's like you could have had crack Stones
return be
you could have had that span over you know
in a differently structured season maybe it
would have uh hit on episode seven and then
concluded in episode 8 so you could really
see what the full extent of his being back
means but yeah he's he's just a big bad that
we need to Vanquish and I think they yeah
it's like it could have been expanded but
I think they chose to focus on the most important
things to give you know resonance to and to
pay off and then I don't think they rushed
anything with him it's like you know you know
what his deal is going to be he's gonna come
back he's gonna be an initially grateful to
Thornhill for raising him up and then he's
gonna go off to his own ass thing and we've
got to put a stop to that so like yeah as
much as it would be like neat to flesh him
out and make him feel like some kind of compelling
interesting villain there's they've done so
much work on so many other things and I think
that again is a nice thing looking back because
they do give you a lot to focus on and a lot
lot of nice red herrings and a lot of things
that you know amount to Something in the greater
tapestry but also you know were fun additions
to this you know propulsive mystery she get
I guess the geoc I didn't watch that dance
episode it's like sprinting what is the geography
of the yeah yeah sprinting into the woods
and I gotta make sure I go around so far away
yeah yeah uh I mean she's gotta know the woods
better than she's been there for so long she
knows the place but yeah it is a little bit
like what are you doing off screen and I wonder
if the stalker if you can go back and watch
the episode this season if you could figure
if you could possibly figure out who the stalker
is I would be fascinated to know yeah somebody
because yeah you can triangulate at least
what scenes to look for them in based on those
pictures so you could maybe I don't know look
at some of those reverse shots in the Weather
Vein or whatever in the cafe I have no idea
who will be it's Eugene It's gotta be Eugene
bastard or it's uh the sheriff the dead Sheriff's
not Sheriff the mayor's son damn Lucas or
whatever his name is I miss you Gwendolyn
Christy I thought you were great I know I'm
sad and now I feel bad and retrospect I'm
like I'm sorry I doubted you I wish I appreciated
you when you were alive I kind of did uh Jenna
Ortega is just uh killed this entire performance
it's not a single week moment yeah she completely
sells and embodies the character and I I and
goodie too like I I really I really love what
she's done here because it's like impressive
but it also feels so natural it's it's it
feels you know I mean Christina Ritchie's
Wednesday Adams is pretty definitive and this
feels absolutely definitive so like you know
props like well done yeah and I think it was
cool to make her the villain because it completely
washes away I feel like it's completely recontextualizes
like on a repeat watch yeah like I was watching
it as a revealing it kind of getting annoyed
at myself of like
yeah yeah which is I think a good a good Twist
Again a good twist reveal when you're like
man should have committed him hitting this
on her yeah because yeah there's a there was
a decent amount and even 10 gentle things
like you think about one of the details we
used and Wednesday uses to be like oh kinbot
it's you as those flowers and you're like
well who else is involved with flowers though
you know like you could even extrapolate things
like that exactly yeah yeah exactly [__]
like this is one of those shows that I'm now
excited to go back and rewatch yeah that is
a great clue bastards bastards man but yeah
I I I think the the growth and journey of
Wednesday I feel like they really do a nice
job to keep her authentic and to never betray
The Roots but to really show what growth looks
like and what vulnerability and what friendship
looks like to a character like this and I
don't know I've seen a lot of people's just
responses out in the world being very grateful
for that because it's kind of shedding light
on an experience that isn't as mainstream
in culture anyway for certain people who do
you know experience life in a more wednesday-esque
fashion I don't know yeah it's like so well
lived in So Perfect they're annoying those
people are idiots all right people comic strip
character it's complete fiction we're talking
about a fictional character not real life
yeah you guys need to get your [__] together
Harry Potter's not really it's just a society
be normal yeah being the message of the show
is to be normal and keep your head down don't
step out of line or call too much attention
to yourself you'll get ripped apart by monsters
yeah I mean overall I thought this was a really
fun episode a fun season I thought this was
really really fun and I see what the excitement's
all about because from beginning to end it's
it uh it was a progressive blast and you know
they flesh out all these friends but they
don't flesh out everyone by the end the other
characters I'm like I don't really know this
person I'm like I can't name who that guy
you don't know Yoko by now I know Yoko because
I was like Yoko the Asians Yoko oh no the
name Yoko Ono yeah of course um so I have
like subconscious reasons of applying your
name um but yeah you have this whole cast
of Friends who stand by her in the end but
you know it's really because of Bianca and
The Nightshade society and whatever uh and
and who plays Enid oh goodness it's everyone's
names and you look up everyone's names now
I know I I almost committed it to memory during
the opening credits that we commented on but
now I can't remember but she's great something
Sinclair yes I want to say none of us can
Google it comment it below guarantee you we
haven't looked it up we will haven't looked
it up by the time this has done being edited
and uploaded we have now looked it up yeah
no she's she's terrific too and I was and
I loved uh I loved I mean obviously you know
you know she's gonna she's got a wolf out
at some point I liked that yeah she gets to
throw down and to really like you know break
in the wolf skin but also I really like the
way they played the end of that and I loved
that shot where she and Ajax it's that wide
profile shot of them where he kind they stop
and then he rushes to her because she's feeling
so kind of vulnerable in that moment and so
shaken by the experience and the way they
like it's a classic kind of a shot where it's
like you're going through the crowd and the
crowd is like oh [__] I felt like a old
school Hollywood set too when when he does
go up to her it felt like out of a black and
white like uh horror film yeah yeah and I
like to horror films so many great little
flourishes like that yeah totally totally
and yeah and even if you don't necessarily
get to know every one of the other kids it's
like they included them enough that it felt
like a real population of students and a real
sort of like oh yeah I kind of know that guy
I kind of know that guy you know this is like
just enough I mean it's a full series so you
know if this was the end I would go oh I don't
want to say this I want to see that oh I wish
you had seen this because they introduced
so many different types of beings that you
don't get to explore really but they keep
it focused on the mystery at hand and that's
what's important that you got to deal with
uh you know you gotta see some of the siren
abilities a little bit you know but they at
the beginning of the first episode they're
like werewolves vampires Sirens you know they're
they're listing them off you don't really
get to see too much of that well that's the
thing is this leaves you with a nice amount
of anticipation because I sit here and I go
well I'm excited to come back to school anyway
like you know a season two will have some
school stuff and I'm excited for that because
I enjoyed that here I'm excited to potentially
see more of this world's take on different
creatures I'm excited for the idea that each
season would probably have a different murder
mystery or mystery of some kind at hand and
two watching this sounds like they have a
very specific mystery set up yes well yeah
the stalker she's probably gonna have to do
like a Clarice startling thing and visit Tyler
Tyler that's right yeah because he sees everything
being the Barista in town someone's following
me that's right you must know who it is and
then I'm I'm sitting here going thinking maybe
specifically towards Buffy I'm like as much
as I'm sad principal Williams is gone I bet
that they could just have a new principle
every season and then kill them and get a
new principle every season I don't know there's
just like so much fun potential and then also
as much as I feel like like for me it's not
a big deal like I'm I've been so thrilled
with what we've been you know enjoying here
but you know there's more you can do with
the various members of The Addams Family too
which is just a nice potential to have on
the horizon I want a Fester episode every
season I think they should do some type of
Netflix special like an hour and a half Adams
Family episode that would be so cool I think
that would be a great like something in between
school do a holiday special yeah I think that
would be a really cool thing to do before
season two comes out yeah or or The Addams
family visits San Francisco
Uncle Fester in there there's so much you
could do yeah yeah I think that would be a
nice little Netflix gets an original movie
out of it yeah and we got and we got Justice
for Xavier we gotta we gotta mention him and
he's I guess gonna pay because his dad's Rich
they're just gonna pay for Wednesday's phone
plan it's like give her a phone with like
a that works that works right and someone
got the number yeah already but I'm not buying
that again all right I'm not buying the Xavier
is in any way involved with that
are you stalking yeah I'm like unknown number
of luggages Xavier's number Xavier it's cooler
when you say Xavier because of X-Men who would
it be
um who's that girl who's not Yoko but who's
always around it's her no idea that girl with
the slick hair who who's something or other
maybe it's uh dude maybe it's that kid with
one testicle from the very first episode with
the piranhas and now he's a freak because
he only has one testicle so he has to go to
Nevermore and he's the stalker well dang all
right guys um this was a fun fun show um sad
it's over apparently's been a really really
fun Journey uh but I'm excited for season
two uh which has already been announced wasn't
she nominated she got a Golden Globe nomination
is she Jenna Ortega yeah did she I think she
did I hope so I mean it's a it is a definitive
performance and it's got
she's a superstar right now yeah yeah and
yeah no she is and I mean she's already been
making a name she's already been standing
out in so many things and now it was I feel
like it was only a matter of time before she
got something like this but this is like the
the best possible scenario yeah before I even
knew who she was I remember watching scream
and yeah I think in our review I was like
she's whoever this actually she should be
this she's the best one in the whole movie
yeah totally no I love watching her like I
I love it's it's funny there's a lot about
the character that's easy to appeal to me
anyway but like I love watching all the life
going on under that deadpan surface because
there is so much and she does so much with
a very restricted emotional performance which
I think is great it never feels restricted
even though she is you know so uh you know
laconic and uh and yeah you know stone-faced
much of the time yeah she's my hair yeah man
she's great all righty well thank you guys
for being here be sure to uh subscribe leave
a like what are you hoping for in Wednesday
season two what was your favorite moment pinpoint
it your favorite moment out of all of Wednesday
how many Mysteries did you call leave it all
down below yeah be sure to subscribe and hey
let's see who the lucky Patron
flev Doran you would drive in Wednesday Adam's
crazy man you would annoy the [__] out
of her because you are so colorful and cheerful
you would be like like a like a Romanian Enid
is what you would be and I think that's what
the show needs next season is a guy like you
in the mix you know bringing your your optimism
and your enthusiasm and you know seeing how
that plays off the goth Macabre Vibes emitted
by so many different characters on this show
but uh you know what no matter how much light
and color might encroach upon the dark we
try to give off you can't help but be susceptible
to it flavior you've got an infectious energy
and no matter where you show up with it I'm
always like I'm happy to hear from flev so
uh hey bud I hope you watched this and I hope
you liked it and I hope you like yourself
and I hope you like living in 2023 because
we're glad you're still here with us never
on pledge or we will uh we'll we'll hide out
we'll turn into hides and we'll come get you
love you buddy stay oh
you just don't stop talking enough for me
to get that into silence wait what
[Music]